the news came as a shock to many new
zealanders prime minister Jacinda ardern
announced her resignation at a media
conference on Thursday I had hoped to
find a way
to prepare not just for another year
but another term because that is what
this year requires
I have not been able to do that
I know what this job takes and I know
that I no longer have enough in the tank
to do it justice
on the streets there was a mixed
reaction oh man I thought she was all
good
for everyone else like this man
why don't you do that I don't think she
was um doing very well in the polls
anyway so you know it's a good time for
her to sit down I think she's looked
after the country over some pretty
difficult times so um yeah kind of wish
her all the best for the future I think
she's done an amazing job with the
situation she's been put in
Arjun LED New Zealand through the
Christchurch massacre in 2019 in which
51 Muslim worshipers were shot dead she
was quick to call it a terror attack
targeting Muslims and in the days
following wore a headscarf when she met
members of the community saying the
country was United in grief Arden was
widely praised for her Swift response to
the covid-19 pandemic New Zealand
imposed some of the toughest pandemic
rules that lasted two years it's
recorded one of the lowest death tolls
from the virus but that came at a cost
recent opinion polls suggest the prime
minister's popularity has dipped and the
labor party's approval ratings are down
with unfulfilled election promises and a
cost of living crisis overseas she's
definitely viewed very well whereas I
think internally she's probably maybe
lost the Public's acceptance a little
bit no it was time for her to go and no
one in their right mind would have been
voted for her surely
ardern was held as a progressive leader
she was only the second woman after
Pakistan's Benazir butcher to give birth
while in office and perhaps what people
will remember most is their empathy and
compassion she showed in moments of
Crisis but in her own words politicians
are human and she has no more to give we
give all that we can for as long as we
can and then it's time
and for me it's time
her last day in office will be February
the 7th
I said Big Al Jazeera